c'est possible sans sexe est le deuxième
sujet ce soir vous réagissiez bien sûr
sur twitter hashtag btp amour les
français ont environ 9 relations
sexuelles par mois mais 47% estiment
pourtant qu'ils peuvent vivre sans sexe
la sexualité abstinence ou au contraire
priorités et addiction on va savoir un
petit peu ce qu'en pensent nos témoins
autour de la table on va savoir vous que
vous en pensez on voit que les plus âgés
disent qu'on peut vivre sans sexe des
plus exceptionnelles
bah c'est vrai qu'on voit minorée à la
regarder gaga mais y'a même pas
tranquille et les plus âgés et karim
zéribi il veut pas d'histoire avec
personne et il veut pas prononcer là
dessus il sait pas on ne peut pas
essayer autre chose que winona lavine
ouais mais sur le sexe oui je peux pas
nier c'est autre chose alors on va dites
nous ce que vous pensez
ben moi mon avis personnel c'est que il
faut être en harmonie sur le plan sexuel
si on veut qu'un couple dure ça me
paraît indispensable
je pense que ça ne suffit pas d'être en
harmonie sont facturés pour qu'un couple
dure mais c'est nécessaire de que pour
qu'il puisse durer et puis je peux
concevoir que deux personnes qui ont je
dirais une une sociabilité identiques
d'un que puisse se passer de sexe ça les
regarde encore une fois si elles sont en
harmonie la question tout à l'heure je
parlais de consentement et de sincérité
un amour là je parlais je parlerais
plutôt d'harmonie si on a deux être en
harmonie qui peuvent se passer de sexe
pourquoi il ne pouvait passer mais sans
sexe moi si je prends mon cas personnel
je pense qu'il faut du sexe pour qu'ils
aient une relation harmonieuse dans un
nettoyage vous dites oui c'est un peu
plus ce week-end mais parce que il ya
notre avis on est chroniqueur après il
ya la vision générale raison et je suis
désolé je puis dire de quelle est obligé
de faire la séparation mais là ce qu'on
vous demande ici le principe de
l'émission choix de démarrer
le principe de l'émission c'est votre
avis c'est pas une question de sondage
on n'est pas dans la famille en or
l'insee arrive dans les rimes a bien
répondu à tes à titre personnel je pense
que non mais autour de moi je vois des
gens qui n'accorde pas beaucoup
d'importance au sexe beaucoup moins que
le reste de la société en accorde et qui
vivent très bien il ya c'est ce qu'on va
dire qu'ils sont malades ignorent ils
sont heureux bon donc je suis obligé de
faire une réponse balance et voilà alors
on un jour dire il ya environ 6,78
milliards rapports sexuels par on est en
france dont 6 milliards chez jimmy
mohamed les français environ 8,8 cette
relation par mois et trois quarts des
français se disent satisfaits de leur
vie sexuelle alors on a un premier
témoin est avec nous c'est jérôme 07 07
ces questions merci et vous bernard
laporte alors vous vous êtes accro au
sexe
bohain alors vous pouvez pas vivre sans
sexe le sexe est primordial dans une
relation à 108 pour 112 112 ont généré
112 à augmenter d'abord de 4 % d'accord
ne pas faire l'amour c'est comme donner
une porsche sans la clé c'est ça alors
on va dire d'autre opel europe al qaîda
est bien entendu est également requise
la volvo la volvo qui est magnifique et
donc quoi donc vous pouvez pas vivre
sans sexe vous êtes mariés non d'accord
vous et vous l'accueil je me marie
pourquoi non non non non je vois plein
fairway non mais j'ai rien dis moi c'est
bon voyez pas l'intérêt
non je suis non quand vous batifoler
nouveaux jeux supportés en fait vous
êtes libertins libertines le buzz donc
il nous a d'esprit donc pour certains
c'est à dire vous allez dans les saunas
et
[Rires]
qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est quoi un
libertin vous allez entrer dans la
cabine tout ça lui avait plein de monde
alors tu peux me tutoyez vous parce que
vous êtes deux bonjour c'est tout seul
avec l'autre jean et dans la nuit
donc jérôme vous habitez au cap d'agde
c'est ça vous êtes non vous êtes dit non
non c'est un saint lazare ou mais un
farfelu au hasard oui donc voilà c'est
vrai même plus à d'accord c'est comme un
c'est ma ville de kindu passé comme un
mec qui aime faire des bêtises et qui
habite à cambrai s'est pas jetée hautes
études caldwell parle beaucoup parler
alors non vous faites l'amour cinq à
sept fois par jour bah c'est pas les
antibiotiques c'est le médicament
gironde fait l'amour cinq à sept heures
par jour ouais mais avec avec qui oui
merde t'as une fois ou pain noir mais
j'ai encore trois ans je rigole jérôme
tu te donne ce profil
non mais à côté de ce que ça quand je
suis avec vous salut je suis avec une
personne sexuellement je m'amuse
beaucoup
oui et vous pourriez pas vivre sans sexe
avec une personne même s'il en est mais
si vous aimez avec la personne tout ça
non non non deux jours je sais que
possible ah oui oui ici si vous élisez
indispensable en fait et si elle veut
pas et qu'elle a indisposé vous faites
comment mais je force personne non mais
vous allez voir ailleurs je suis
libertine
c'est ce que ces libertés oui vous avez
connu vers tanger dans les saunas hills
mais non mais c'est pas les mêmes
[Rires]
mais sa liberté entravée pas n'a jamais
les personnes partant chez sûr que si ça
va quoi s'agit il faut pas tout mélanger
liberté c'est pas le pervers de base le
cap d'agde de non plus être moins
d'accord voilà moi j'aimerais quand même
je fais l'amour je ne baisse pas comme
tu prétends le annonce est utile ici je
le vois comme ça tu connais même toit
le hamac ou attraper la même en tunisie
[Applaudissements]
donc voilà donc on voit que jérôme giron
de toi tu est accro au sexe donc voilà
on a on agit les mines à côté à côté
vous avez 50 et 60 ans oui moi j'ai 61
ans et lui la longueur de bateau à
palavas les flots
oui vous êtes scotchés ensemble vous
dites depuis 34 ans oui vous avez
rencontré gilles vous avez rencontré
mina vous n'aviez que 15 ans c'est ça
non incroyable tromper vous avez quel
âge men cinq mineurs en plus non mais
c'est vrai il à l'époque il y avait
détournement de mineure mais non je ne
sais pas ben non mais c'est vrai quand
même oui mais vous avez chez vous vous
êtes resterez vous êtes vous avez connu
à 15 ans ou comment ça s'est passé
ben c'était la voisine de mes copains en
fait quand j'allais voir le soir paru
avec la mobylette je vais arriver ça ne
3 way et 23 sport jantes à bâtons en
scène trois l'ambition à l'aller les
séries l'algérie est en fait je
regardais la voisine je l'abats dé quoi
je vois là est amené ce petit lay jeu et
et voilà et je dis je la veux je
d'accord ces films nina j'ai pas
d'élections
voilà je tombé fou amoureux d'elle que
qu'au premier regard vous l'accord est
depuis mai on se quitte réciproque le
coup de foudre et aimé
mais non c'était pas de système pas pour
moi ah oui là dedans avec 1go qu'isa et
demi ça a été compliqué mais bon ça
c'est fait alors alors c'est vrai que
vous avez vu la réaction de mes je dis
tout de suite il a été choqué voyez ce
que vous l'avez connu à 15 ans et mine
de rien c'est vrai que c'est un
détournement de mineure qui avec hélas
je connais bien sûr non mais jusqu'à
minuit il avait 18 ans non mais c'est
vrai que c'est un détournement de mineur
et il faut quand même se rappeler que
c'est interdit par la loi bien sûr
exactement non mais c'est vrai et donc
pas ce que vous dites ça arrive mais
vous lui avez tout à prix au niveau du
sexe oui c'est le coin dit ça moi je
sais mon niveau 6 allée au courant mina
non mais oui parce que la première fois
qu'on bon il ya méfier qu'écoutaient mes
trois filles et je suis désolé mais
comment elles ont quel âge ofii à ben
elle a 30 ans l'autre 38 et raccords bon
très bien et donc alors à côté nous est
bien la première fois que donc on est
allé se coucher il est rentré dans le
lit tout habillé avec jean à tous le
beffroi
je tends cowboys mais la fois les
chaussettes tous donc bien voilà je lui
ai dit écoute déjà bien toi sinon on va
je dirige est évident que la génération
sortez couverts alors et est donc est
donc dans là c'est vrai qu'il n'avait
jamais fait l'amour à wissant normale à
15 en plus j'étais en fin d'émission
mais que dire alors de la majorité
sexuelle on dit que la majorité sexuelle
ses 15 ans et 3 mois que c'est
directement et voilà ses 16 ans
effectivement la majorité sexuelle mais
c'est vrai que faut pas prôner
effectivement le détournement de mineur
bien sûr mais ce qui est formidable
c'est quand même trente quatre ans les
années que vous êtes qui vous unissent
depuis ce temps là et vous vous êtes
jamais quitté ses et nordine jamais on
est un tout le temps que le temps
ensemble ont déjà l'impression que cette
différence est une vraie force chez vous
on travaille ensemble
on fait tout un symbole et toujours
alors justement en parlant de jamie
ensemble et je ne conçois pas et par une
journée
le jour je n'avais pas marre de tout
comme toute la journée koné et après tu
parlais des femmes avec les celles là le
mach est né tout près et par ma femme
est la soixantaine un peu levé le truc
les signes sont là quoi alors justement
comme son nom n'est pas là vous dites
que vous pouvez pas concevoir d'avoir du
bonheur tous les deux sens aix voilà
c'était le thème c'est le deuxième thème
c1 on va voir qu'il ya d'autres gens qui
pensent le contraire
ici vous ne consommez pas une relation
sans sexe oui bin oui oui et en plus moi
je trouve que un couple je trouve que
c'est monotone s'il n'y a pas quelque
part du sexe a déjà et on se connaît par
coeur et quand même on ne trouve quand
même l'occasion de faire l'amour
un peu partout voilà d'accord et donc
pour vous monsieur c'est votre première
et seule partenaire à ses produits il
faut que ça va changer pour les
apprendre qu'à bouaké ce cas après il a
jugé qu'il y est il ya eu une bauge
était gravement malade quoi ce qui nous
a beaucoup rapprochés de l'âge de 30 ans
à aujourd'hui
et en ce qui te plus on sens de l'amour
au centre de la fiction ça y est dans
votre relation on sent qu'il va chemin
solide parce que elle se limite pas
comme je le disais tout à l'heure au
sexe soit s'il n'a pas fait le bonheur
de l'amour quoi exactement
non mais je pense que le bonheur que oui
le bonheur est possible son sexe pas
toujours pas dans toutes les
circonstances vous serez dû arriver
ah oui ah oui depuis peu de tout mais
oui je sais que vous avez les dossiers
non mais je dire que plusieurs plusieurs
mois les dossiers donc allez-y non mais
par exemple lorsqu'un couple se
rencontre
je pense que le sexe est indispensable
pour nous et le couple faire grandir le
faire évoluer parfois la tendresse prend
le pas sur le couple
après peut-être 30 ans peut-être que ce
n'est pas votre cas mais après vingt ans
parfois la tendresse prend le pas
parfois on a un enfant dans le couple et
l'enfant et éloigne aussi le sexe ça
n'empêche pas l'amour
donc c'est pour ça que je dis que oui
pour moi le bonheur est possible sans
sexe dans certaines conditions dans
certains cas alors il ya gilles morin
des psychanalystes et sexologue à paris
qui lui pense comme vous on peut
parfaitement trouvé son équilibre son
sexe tout à fait oui je pense que le
bonheur est nécessaire enfin l'amour et
nécessaires au bonheur par contre le
sexe n'est pas forcément nécessaire
ça ne gâche rien on est d'accord mais
c'est pas forcément nécessaire il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas faim
qu'ils sont dans une misère sexuelle
pour des tas de raisons diverses par
exemple maladies cancers diabètes
difficulté endocriniennes of hugo
pâtissent côté de couple mais qui
situation
social et qui pour autant peuvent être
heureux sinon la moitié de nos
concitoyens frais vouée au malheur on
peut quand même être heureux malgré tout
mais c'est comme ça on peut avoir un
bras de moins et être heureux quand même
mais vaut mieux avoir deux bras est
d'accord sur un bon exemple merci sans
baisser alors vous dites aussi que les
prêtres par exemple arrive parfaitement
à être heureux sans sexualité et
justement on à leur manière
alors on a au nom là je pense que la
perversion elles existent indépendamment
de la religion
il ya des gens qui sont pervers
effectivement mais c'est le détournement
des règles mais ça existe aussi en
dehors de la religion mais c'est pas
bien sûr je suis d'accord avec vous
alors il ya le père nathanaël garric qui
est avec nous prêtre catholique 36 ans
vous habitez avec son provence est fin
et vous avez l'impression d'être heureux
et épanoui son sexe alors moi j'ai en
tout cas l'envoi sont peut être
complètement malheureux dans la vie ou
slc sur d'accord et de fait ça fait
quelques années que les biens j'ai
promis aux seigneurs de vivre de manière
célibataire vous avez déjà eu des
relations pas avant alors en fait moi je
dois vous dire que depuis que je suis
jeune j'ai compris que enfin voilà avoir
des relations sexuelles c'est quelque
chose d'important et que je me dis si un
jour je le fais pas je dirais que ça a
tout son sens et donc je voudrais
pouvoir attendre le mariage ou autre
chose on ne l'avait jamais fait et du
coup je me suis dit ben voila je même
réservé pour le jour où est en fête bat
au jour narayanan ont finalement j'ai
compris que j'étais appelé à autre chose
à un amour plus grand et en fait j'ai
choisi avant même d'être prêtre j'ai
choisi d'être célibataire d'être
célibataire pour dieu parce que j'ai
compris que c'était 7 de cette manière
là que je pourrais dire adieu tout mon
amour parce que je défends ressenti son
propre amour pour moi un chien c'est
l'offre totale alors vous dites quand on
a des relations sexuelles avant le
mariage
notre corps et notre coeur ne sont pas
en accord alors c'est une vidéo
effectivement que j'ai fait à
destination des jeunes qui se posent des
questions sur l'amour qui se pose des
questions par rapport au mariage est le
but de cette vidéo c'était de les aider
à réfléchir parce que précisément jeu il
me semble que c'est absolument
fondamental pour un couple d'avoir des
relations sexuelles
parce que moi autour de vous savez donc
moi je passe beaucoup de temps avec des
jeunes je passe beaucoup de temps avec
des couples et tout ce que j'entende me
disent que combien le fait d'avoir des
relations sexuelles c'est quelque chose
qui est fortifié leur couple assure
pourtant pour l'épanouissement du couple
et ça vous voulant vous l'entendez quand
même à bien sûr c'est évident c'est la
base
c'est un couple qui veut durer dans le
temps doit avoir des relations sexuelles
ça c'est évident où vous avez pris le
parti d'être célibataire mais moi j'ai
fait un choix très particulier
fectivement j'ai fait le job vous êtes
plus haut j'ai fait le show se passe il
est puceau cd mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'elle respecte choisi de ne pas
avoir de relations sexuelles 36 ans a
bien offert est bon choix même s'il
avait moi j'ai pas j'aime pas renoncer à
l'amour et je crois que c'est ça qu'il
il a choisi de cuisson depuis depuis
votre repose et va très vite et
d'ailleurs quel âge vous avez confié 15
ans à peu près à la voilà je me suis
déterminé pour rester comme ça dans ma
vie là et je les choisis et j'échoue je
vais choisir ne pas renoncer à l'amour
et ça pour moi que le plus important ce
tribunal mais qu'est ce que vous pensez
des religions qui autorise le mariage
des prêtres et donc les relations
sexuels des prêtres ou là y'a pas
d'antagonisme entre l'amour de dieu et
l'amour bien sûr mais bien sûr mais
d'ailleurs même le célibat des prêtres
enfin il ya des prêtres mariés même dans
l'église catholique vous savez pas dans
l'église latine mais dont donc moi je
sais face et c'est super c'est
fantastique ça posait aucun problème
mais c'est que c'était pas mon désir à
moi moi mon désir c'était de nous
consacrer à dieu et ensuite c'était le
choix du sacerdoce est ce que est ce que
vous avez déjà été amoureux
oui je pense qu'on peut le dire pas fou
amoureux à foix murdochville sentinelle
et parfois mais des sentiments amoureux
bah oui bien sûr vous en avez vous en
avez ressenti dernièrement je suis pas
je peux dire dernièrement en tout cas le
fait que ce qui est sûr c'est que je ne
suis pas insensible au charme d'une
belle fille ça c'est vrai non ah oui bah
oui je suis pas fait de boire non mais
c'est important de le dire vous
maîtrisez comment vous arrivez à à gérer
ses pulsions de la pierre oui mais c'est
une vraie importance et des vraies
questions je remercie dans un choc on en
parle en fait voyez pour moi et là je
vois bien donc tous ces énergies et ses
pulsions et en fait moi c'est comment
dire je
j'ai l'impression que les transcender
pour une cause plus grande oui pour un
amour en ce mois le fait d'être
célibataire ça me permet sincèrement
d'être plus disponible plus disponible
pour savez quand vous avez des pauvres
autour de vous ils viennent vous
déranger le soir viennent chercher un
toit en abri chez pas quoi heureusement
vous avez pas une famille en même temps
enfin voilà le célibat me donne une
vraie disponibilité pour tous les gens
qui en ont besoin et après je pense
voter mais je pense que sting par un peu
d' équilibre de vie
je veux dire maintenant ma vie j'ai déjà
des amis
enfin je m'appelais mais gil vaugelade
arrive d'être attiré par une personne
ben oui ça fait partie de la vie fait
quoi dans ce cas là bas c'est ce que
j'essaye d'expliquer un petit peu pour
moi c'est autre chose c'est à dire que
j'essaie de d'abord le chaque jour je
reçois zee le fait d'être célibataire
pour dieu tous les matins je me dis
voilà ça c'est le choix de ta vie et
tous les matins je suis heureux de faim
voilà de ça et du coup d'abord c'est pas
un truc qui met un baril c'est pas un
truc qui m'est imposé ou que je n'ai pas
choisi je ne subis pas mon célibat je
les choisis et j'ai l'impression voilà
la manière dont vous parler que 15 jours
pour vous dire un matin je me réveille
et en fait non je vais peut-être choisir
un lendemain j'ai choisi je me suis
engagé j'ai donné une promesse pour la
vie mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
c'est pas il suffit pas de dire un jour
hop voilà j'ai décidé après savoureux un
jour mais ce que je vais en fait je
pense que ça a déjà pu plus ou moins
m'arriver a peint ou peut-être que ça
m'arrivera encore d'une manière ils vont
renoncer
mais est-ce que j'ai c'est que la
création la question c'est comment est
ce que je choisis comme ans que
j'accueille ou non ce sentiment amoureux
mais j'ai envie de dire c'est pour
quelqu'un qui a envie d'être fidèle à
son époux à son épouse un peu la mairie
on peut calculer ça vous conforte dans
votre idée c'est à dire que nous devons
traduire des jo point fr ça parce que
j'ai pas demandé non mais oui en quelque
sorte un confortable vous donnera force
dans le sens où moi ce qui me plaît
pourquoi est ce que mon ces débats elle
a du sens c'est parce qu'un coup tu sais
que c'est un cadeau aux jacobins
c'est un cadeau que j'ai voulu faire il
faut que ça fait du bien ça non mais
c'est ça je sens que ça beaucoup de ski
et voilà vous voit où il dit que vous
pouvez êtes attiré par unsa mais pas
pour être attirés vous pouvez peut-être
tombé amoureux mais vraiment vous mettez
des barrières oui karim d'un mois avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour la
religion catholique et je pense qu'il
faut éviter de faire des raccourcis
faciles et malvenue avec les actualités
dramatique qu'on peut voir qui touchent
l'église parce que on n'a pas le droit
de faire des amalgames donc et de porter
atteinte à l'ensemble des catholiques
qui sont je suis convaincu fort
respectable comme toutes les autres
religions
mais l'homme je m'interroge je sais que
quelque part c'est dommage parce que
c'est c'est pas à l'origine que votre
célibat vous êtes imposés
c'est l'évolution de l'église de cas à
l'origine les prêtres avaient le droit
de vivre et de se marier et si je peux
me permettre et aller au bout nous
donner le sentiment que vous luttez
c'est sa maman qui me gêne c'est ce qui
donnait le sentiment d'être un peu d'un
tunnel
deux postures contre nature et duke nord
or si je vais au bout de ma réflexion
est-ce qu'on peut lutter durablement
est-ce qu'on peut être dans la contre
nature durablement
moi je pense que qu'on se disait même
série la raison est ce que je me dis
aussi moi ce que je pense un peu comme
karim ce que je me dis comme vous dites
vous dit vous faites tous les jours un
cadeau à dieu oui est ce qu'à un moment
vous n'avez pas vous dire c'est comme un
couple qui méritent tous les matins ils
peuvent sereinement on se sont désolés
non mais le couple marié là sa femme le
même classe et ça ne va pas voir
ailleurs mis la safa nouveaux habits qui
physiquement là on n'avait rien alors à
tous déjà qui dicte que dans son île dit
que dans le couple marié on se maîtrise
pour ne pas les voir ailleurs mais oui
c'est la même maîtrise ni les voir
demain tu as une roue la dernière
question c'est très juste très
clairement
m si physiquement vous avez une pulsion
sexuelle c'est à dire vous avez une
érection comment vous maîtrisez est-ce
que c'est mental
qu'est ce que vous faites concret le
nier c'est que c'est pour moi c'est
inclus de manière globale dans ma vie le
fait d'apprendre à maîtriser ses
pulsions
est ce que je vous disais c'est que ben
pour moi ça ne peut passer que par un
équilibre de vie
c'est à dire que évidemment mais voilà
faut dormir chez moi j'ai beaucoup
besoin d'étudier dans la maquette a voté
la décharge il n'a pas beaucoup il fuit
je pense que c'est un phénomène qu'on
appelle la sublimation gilles qui en
fait la pulsion sexuelle elle est
dirigée par un but allez allez au départ
physiologique animal va vers un but et
quand ce but sexuel est interdit par des
principes par exemple des règles bâle et
elle peut être détourné alors soit les
reflets et le refoulement ça que ça crée
des fantasmes sacré des envies qui
peuvent après créer des passages à
l'acte c'est chercher chez certains et
quand elle n'est pas refouler elle peut
être sublime et donc leur elle passe pas
dans l'inconscient allait aller
volontairement détourné ce cas me suis
dit tu cours voilà on va chercher un
petit tuyau va ailleurs et ça peut être
détournée badens dans la foi ça peut
détourner dans la cuisine où peut avoir
une sexualité sans jeter l'opprobre
encore une fois parce qu'en grand
respect pour pour votre choix de clichés
vous appartient mais on peut se poser la
question se substitue est-ce qu'il est
durable humainement parlant
est-ce qu'on peut voler sa sensibilité
son émotion amis ne sais pas il a 36 ans
des missions et cyril vous souvenez qui
avait basculé cadiet moment donné je
plains les symptômes amoureux de cette
femme et jadida lors bois métal quoi
être sûr d'aller vous savez dans son c
est ce que fait apprécier c'est pas le
sujet mais comme on vous à la catho
telle église il faut que l'on ouvre le
débat là bas je pense que le débat il
est ouvert on parle de l'église en
général alors s'il vous plaît on a en a
qu'on a quelqu'un qui est pas du même
avis enfin qui est pas du même avis qui
respecte certainement c'est jessica pire
mais vous êtes sexothérapeute et
coachant sexualité vous dites vous que
le bonheur n'est pas possible sans sexe
il manque toujours une partie au sein du
couple
alors expliquez nous moi je la compagne
des couples au quotidien je vois très
bien la frustration des couples quand
ils viennent c'est parce qu'il ya eu une
absence de une absence de sexualité et
dont ils sont frustrés
donc pour moi clairement il manque une
partie et je suis d'accord que trois
piliers dans le couple il ya l'amitié
les sentiments amoureux et pour moi le
troisième pilier c'est la sexualité et
la manière de créer l'intimité dans le
couple c'est aussi la sexualité parce
que qu'est ce qui nous distingue
finalement d'un ami dans notre de notre
meilleur pote voix basse et l'acte
sexuel en fait ça pour moi ça me paraît
évident que oui mais il ya des gens qui
vivent voilà qui vivent très bien parce
que voilà ils sont tellement amies avec
leurs conjoints qui n'ont peut être plus
besoin voilà je ne sais pas ça ça arrive
au bout agathe vous vous êtes vous dit
non
penser qu'on peut pas vivre heureux son
sexe je pense qu'en tout cas au sein de
la relation amoureuse je pense que les
notions de d'excitation de désir de
l'autre sont des notions centrales et je
dirais même que quand ce justement ce
désir s'amenuisent se réduit avec le
temps c'est souvent ce moment là où le
couple se délite un peu ou se séparent
ou on bascule effectivement dans une
forme de tendresse ou d'affections comme
tu l'avais dit christine mais à ce
moment là j'ai l'impression qu'un manque
se fait ressentir et qu'on le cherche
forcément ailleurs
j'ai l'impression que le sexe est
vraiment centrale dans une relation
amoureuse et moi je n'imaginerais pas si
je suis avec mon amoureux et que je
ressens pas de désir pour lui je peux
pas l'envisager amoureusement
[Applaudissements]
elle te dirais tu te dis trop peur il a
eu peur qu'elle balance un peu suivi
mohamed je suis pas très à l'aise sur le
sujet je vais pas vous mentir
d'autant plus que mes parents regarder
ma belle mère aussi donc
mais je pense que ça fait partie de
l'équipe une en brasse votre belle mère
d'air on l'a vu tout nu dans les loges
tout et il est très sage vraiment à
l'oreille donc je pense que cette partie
déquilibre d'un couple au delà la
fonction reproductive et je le rends
compte aussi en consultation lorsque des
gens ont des problèmes on se rend compte
que l'équilibré perturbé tant pour
l'homme que pour la femme et que
derrière ça et souvent un mal être et
que lorsqu'on répond à ce mal être qu'on
propose des traitements des esseulés et
d'aider des thérapies les choses peuvent
aller mieux d'autant plus qu'il ya des
études on en a parlé qui le disent avoir
douze rapports par mois nous ferait
paraître plus jeune de dix ans là qu'on
se rend compte qu eric naulleau a pris
un petit coup de vieux mais c'est bon
pour la santé
oui les attaques gratuites est gratuite
mais c'est alesi jimmy a dit la vérité
parce qu'il s'appelle jean alesi alors
vérité qui dérange balancé tu vas voir
ta belle mère
et des voitures on sait que cette
diminue l'anxiété
ça améliore la qualité du sommeil et le
bien-être donc je pense que dans la vie
d'un couple c'est vital même si on sait
très bien que dans le bonheur en général
si on est seul et qu'on a une maladie on
peut aussi être heureux sans ça mais
dans un couple je pense que c'est
nécessaire
oui et eric revel riche en or à ce qu'
il ya deux périodes dans la vie quand le
développement hormonal encore là où on
peut être très heureux très amoureux
sans qui est sexe la première période
pour moi c'est quand on est tout petit
on peut tomber éperdument amoureux de
quelqu'un l'aimé à la folie est d'avoir
une rupture mal mais n'en génère mais je
je je termine si je peux me permettre
évidemment il peut pas les bras non mais
on peut aimer quelqu'un sans qu'il y ait
du sexe alors donc ça c'est quand on est
tous assez la premier et quand on
commence à avoir ses morts et barzola le
développement harmonieux
c'est un peu on peut être super heureux
sans avoir de 5,5 donc je pense que dans
les deux cas de figure on peut être très
amoureux vivre un parfait bonheur en
couple 100 kg et de sexe est à l'abri en
hongrie cazé 15 et 40 ans on en fait
quoi qu'est ce qui se passe à celle ci
allait ronald chez vous elle est assez
pensé
enfin on fait du sénat ba bien sûr il y
en a et et vous dire que vous en pensez
vous pour vivre moi sans sexe non peut
pas leur est il possible sans sexe non
c'est pas possible
après pourquoi ben y'a pas de sexe après
c'est qui qui va faire quoi c'est qu'il
[Rires]
va faire les petites choses que vous
pouvez pas dire son nom ça aurait pu
avoir une relation son sexe ben si un
peu de sexe et à la main droite et je
préfère le sexe à droixhe et la
sexualité
là on entend ya trois piliers on entend
des choses très définitive on peut pas
vivre sans moi j'ai pas c'est pas mon
cas j'ai changé mon vote parce que j'ai
discuté avec agathe et jimmy qui me faut
que tu répondes pour toi pour moi c'est
non mais j'ai rencontré avec des gens
qui honnêtement me disent ça ne
m'intéresse pas et contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire l'entendre il ya
pas mal y'a pas mal d'hommes dans ce cas
on a l'impression des sexualités la
suite non iliad est inclus moi c'est pas
mon truc mais détruit la question sinon
il se forge intéresse plus nos miss non
ça les a jamais intéressé alors
justement ils écoutent l'émission il ya
des gens qui leur disent il vous manque
quelque chose il ya une dimension
connaissais pas moi je trouve sa brutale
de mettre des gens aux normes alors que
eux sincèrement vous dites je vis très
bien son sexe alors je me tue à toi
non on a on à lily rose avec loi 18 ans
vous êtes étudiante vous êtes à sexuelle
vous êtes en couple avec un autre à
sexuelle la sexualité c'est ne pas
ressentir du tout de désir sexuel vous
en êtes rendu compte avec votre ex vous
l'avez quitté car vous ne vouliez plus
avoir de relations sexuelles vous vous
culpabiliser y est auprès de lui vous
aviez l'impression de le priver de
quelque chose et vouliez vous vouliez
pas du tout le forcez vous vous vous
voyez jamais faire l'amour de votre vie
vous avez rencontré votre petite amie
sur un blog da sexuelle voilà qui est
dit alors racontez nous un lit les roses
vous vous vous êtes heureuse sans sexe
et vous êtes avec quelqu'un voilà qu'est
que heureux comme vous sans sexe voilà
en fait il faut comprendre que je ne
suis pas devenu en fait c'est enfin j'ai
toujours ressenti en quelque sorte sauf
que je ne connaissais pas cet homme d'à
sexualité donc en fait voilà
effectivement je suis tombé sur ce
blogue
et là je suis resté bouche bée est ce
que c'est exactement ce qui
correspondait à vous donner vous ne
ressentez pas de désir sexuel
non est ce que vous avez vu un médecin
par exemple c'est pas du tout un
jugement de valeur
jusqu'au nettement un problème médical
ou psychologique qui ferait que vous
n'avez pas de désir par exemple un
problème hormonal pourrait faire qu'il
n'y a pas de désir
un examen gynécologique ou une
échographie pelvienne pourrait peut-être
décelé des choses est ce que cette
démarche a été fait déceler une
pathologie thyroïdienne des choses de
base qui vous ferait dire très bien je
n'ai pas de problème médical ou
psychologique
c'est un choix délibéré de vie est ce
que vous avez déjà fait ces démarches
alors non ce n'est pas fait mais pour la
simple et bonne raison qu'en fait je
connais des personnes qui le sont et qui
ont dit que je l'avais fait je pense que
c'est insuffisant je pense que la
première des démarches c'est à les
consulter
et puis peut-être que tout sera normal
et puis très bien je ne dis pas que vous
êtes malade vous souffrez de quelque
chose mais je pense que si on tombait
sur quelque chose
un problème au niveau danone dano vers
une prise de sang est normal peut-être
que les choses changeraient que votre
vie serait différente ou pas j'en serais
sympa mais quand même bien même je serai
malade et j'entends ce que vous dites je
suis d'accord mais quand bien même je
serai malade j'ai pas envie de changer
ça je trouve
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il me manque
quelque chose en fait je le vis bien
alors vous avez vous avez connu votre
votre conjoint sur un blog de sexuel et
vous vous êtes très bien comme ça avec
votre conjoint lui aussi il n'a jamais
eu une relation sexuelle où il s'est
rendu compte
en ayant des relations que voilà qui
s'était pas son truc pour être franc je
n'ai jamais vraiment parlé avec luc ce
que je respecte sa vie privée
d'accord et donc voilà et vous êtes vous
traverse jamais l'esprit d'avoir une
relation avec lui non mais vous n'êtes
pas comme vous dites à quelqu'un vous
dit mademoiselle que vous n'avez pas de
relations sexuelles c'est à dire que
j'étais chaud ainsi et c'est vrai si
gênant à la famille qui regarde voilà il
ya la belle-mère deux heures et tout est
beau mais ça veut dire que vous dans
votre relation avec votre conjoint votre
ami même pas de caresses de choses comme
ça
si vous il ya des buts hausse à fignon
ou ça débute ou jamais non mais je veux
dire par là c'est quoi c'est actuel
parce que fait des bisous quand même
fait des alors libre les visuels et
canon je trouve que ça n'a rien à voir
avec la sexualité bien sûr mais je suis
d'accord non non tu prends sur moi il
peut y avoir des cas moi je suis pas
d'accord c'est de la sexualité
ah oui on réduit trop la sexualité à
l'acte au koïfhus ça ça me dérangerait
scotia de la sexualité donc donc vous
avez envie de l'embrasser votre vote
rouge ont alors ouais donc voila vous
vous ressentez quand même de la tirade
sur lattes de l'attirance physique quand
même malgré tout oui pourquoi pas
l'embrasser en fait quand vous
l'embrassez vous sentez vous êtes
attirés vous avez envie de l'embrasser
pour eux tu faire une petite marque
d'affection ou bien c'est parce que vous
avez vraiment envie de l'embrasser à ce
moment là pour être franc j'ai je n'ai
jamais embrassé parce qu'on ne sait
jamais vu encore ah ouais
[Musique]
mais c'est déjà un bracelet petit a déjà
embrassé mon ex et c'est vrai que moi je
ne mélange pas j'ai tendance est vrai à
limiter le sexe peuvent pour la barrière
en tout cas moi je la trouve très
mignonne mais franchement je conviens
faux témoignage au real il est très
mignon et c'est celui dont vous n'avez
jamais vu votre fiancée mais ça fait
longtemps que cet ensemble bah c'est pas
officiels en fait mais ça fait un an que
je connais bien allez vous voir ou à
c'est quoi le truc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous coûter à ba oui d'accord mais je ne
sais pas pour l'instant on n'a pas on
n'a pas seulement que justement pour
l'instant on le vit très bien comme
quand vous allez voir ce n'est pas
vouloir l'embrasser ça changerait page
je suis pas quelque chose qui va changer
comme ça je me définis comme à sexuelle
parce que j'ai jamais ressenti ce désir
envers quelqu'un dans la boue avec vos
parents pardon j'en ai parlé que vos
parents n'ont pas du dfe ils le
découvrent la zeebo nous regarde quel
point la sexualité ci mais j'ai pas à
parler de mes relations forcément avec
mes copains mais votre conjoint et puis
comment il vous plaît ce garçon non ce
que je dis là elle a vu qu'en photo il
est loin c'est ça la question vous le
tuez wave ou bonjour vous faites quelque
chose dans votre esprit je vous dis
acadie envoyé aux intellectuels ou est
ce que c'est qu'un intellectuel vous
échanger des trucs à l'anneau laulan
propre nom mais rose vous êtes alors que
les voyages faut que dans le sirh et
vous allez voir votre copain lui taper
la bise ballon mais pas la défense je
suis pas bien sûr que si on verra si je
me mets à l'acte sexuel et embrassades a
dit la sociologue
enfin la sexologue que c'est un acte
vous téléphonez vous parlez vous de tous
les jours nous a pas trop le cas
[Rires]
par les voûtes et déployer tous les
chemins et les jours mais j'en ai marre
de cette amoureuse oui comment vous le
sentez alors vous êtes amoureuse comme
toi je pensais pas de leclerc qui perd
j'aimerais j'aimerais avoir l'avis
j'aimerais avoir la vidéo non mais cyril
je trouve que votre votre témoignage est
quand même très émotionnel mahilé il
dégage quelque chose je trouve aussi
deux nouveaux jeux en bout sans briller
voici très franchement je sais j'ai
l'air sombre l'âme aussi chez j'aime
beaucoup témoin n'a vu les libéraux ce
soir justement gilles puis qu'analyste
et sexologue l'article je trouve beau
c'est qu'on est dans une société
d'agents ctions à jouer ou de
normalisation alors le fait est ce que
vous avez fait des examens est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de plainte en fait dans le dsm
5 et la classification des troubles
mentaux
il n'y a que six à du dégoût du sexe ou
un roger siv est une réaction à une
formation réactionnelle quelque chose
qu'il y avait là il n'y a pas de n'ya
pas de plainte il ya pas mal dans mon
métier je reçois des gens avec une
plante je suis pas normalisateurs je
vais pas les obliger à être comme ci ou
comme ça je pars de et on est dans une
société qui a une injonction c'est métro
boulot marmots porno dodo il faut
absolument être à sonder l'avis de eric
naulleau
vous n'avez par rapport à ça ça cache
une grande misère sexuelle tard on a on
a on a un besoin de désir lors il peut y
avoir des besoins a besoin ça se
satisfait on est tranquille mais le
désir ça se satisfait pas le lendemain
on aime encore sa femme
voilà encore et ça s'est il sait jamais
ce qui est troublant c'est qu'on pose
beaucoup plus de questions à cette jeune
femme sur son absence de sexualité qu'on
en pause à des gens qui ont faim de
notoriété publique des sexualité
déviante comme jimmy mohamed ou karim
zéribi comment on questionne une absence
alors que ces oran à temps mais je veux
pas m'avancer mais amène à 20000 a bien
mis deux ou trois de denrées la
punchline faute est libre c'est que tu
t'éclates vous savez que si ricco on
sait que ça les conséquences médicales
que je vous donnais aussi c'est ça qui
abordera lisible par rapport à ce que
dit le spécialiste qui est à côté de moi
c'est vrai qu'on est quand même d'une
société très codé on a l'impression que
si on n'est pas dans la norme en sept
différentes cela est presque vécu comme
une tare or c'est presque de l'irrespect
de ce que peut être la nature même d'une
personne et ça a été le cas sur
l'homosexualité il ya encore quelques
décennies où on disait il ya même des
gens qui ont dit assez récemment excusé
moi à l'église a parlé de psychiatrie ou
machines zombies sur l'homosexualité
il ya des gens je pense qu'il faut
respecter leur leur leur intimité la
manière dont ils décident de vivre leur
intimité
les conséquences de vivre sans sexe et
c'est vrai que ça a des conséquences sur
la santé par exemple une augmentation du
stress
voilà que bernard laporte n'est jamais
stressé mais le manque de rapports
sexuels empêche l'organisme de réduire
la pression sanguine qui augmente lors
de situations stressantes
il ya un manque de confiance en soi lors
d'un rapport sexuel des hormones
circulent dans notre sens permettant de
se sentir mieux dans notre tête
lorsqu'on ne fait plus l'amour le manque
se fait donc ressentir l'année moi par
exemple j'ai un manque de confiance en
moi
mais un système immunitaire ça vous fait
rien nous trouver des solutions pour
contrer des solutions mais mais c'est ça
il ya un système immunitaire fragilisé
c'est vrai un dhimmi mois m on m'a
arrêté suite une bêtise je vais pas
qu'on était dans le docteur mais si sa
belle mère peut venir chercher la
production d'immunoglobuline qui nous
aide à lutter contre les virus c'est mon
papa est médecin donc je connais un
petit peu ça et les bactéries qui traîne
et diminuer le corps est donc privé
d'une ligne de défense importante est
importante et bien sûr des troubles de
l'érection un homme ayant fréquemment
des rapports sexuels à 50% de risque en
moins d'avoir des problèmes d'érection
bon voilà donc je vous dis c'est des
vrais problèmes de santé voilà dix huit
ans quand on dirait qu'ils vendent être
sûr nous rejoignent et lui c'est s'est
bâti 0 il il est accro au sexe voilà il
peut pas vivre sans sexe
il habite au cap d'agde comme quoi le
nougat tabitha montélimar prédestiné
donc les conseils de mission sexe on les
a vus et on a quelqu'un qui s'appelle
charles qui est dans public il n'a
jamais couché avec une fille charles
idées ou chat merci charles charles levé
vous il voulait témoigner ce soir merci
d'être avec nous charles vous pouvez
vous lever et courageux soir charles
charles merci d'être là vraiment vous
avez 25 ans ça fait quoi dans la vie
je suis en bac pro dans le maintenance
des équipements industriels un point de
reprendre le micro bien vous êtes donc
je suis en bac pro il a marqué 11 des
équipements industriels d'accord va très
bien c'est très bien j'aime beaucoup
alors vous n'avez jamais eu une relation
sexuelle mais j'aime ça ça vous dérange
pas juste de le dire comme ça à la télé
vous vos amis voilà son cours ans et
c'est pas voyons les émissions kourou
pourquoi alors est ce que c'est un choix
personnel ou bien ce que c'est parce que
vous n'avez pas trouvé l'occasion ou la
fille qui vous plaît assez pour pour en
avoir avec elle ou le gars ont trouvé
plutôt le chi chi dans le jeune de
chemise merci non je records le soir le
rachat mais après ça va merci alors
charles donc n'est jamais voilà une
attirance assez importante pour une pour
une fille pour aller au bout c'est ça
oui au fait je n'arrive pas à conclure
que je suis du coup j'aime assez ce à
quoi le vicieux chan qui n'arrivent pas
à conclure avec les filles charles quint
tu dis conclure pardonne moi de te
tutoyer mais tu es tu lui retombera dans
les détails voir mon fils tu flirte même
pas où tu flirt et chariots pas passé le
cap de l'or là je n'ai jamais voulu
heurter avec une fille m'a tant donné je
me proposais d' timide en fait c'est ça
oui timide ec120 que vous arrive est
copain avec des filles parce que voilà
mais peut être que politique c'est parce
que je vous dis la vérité charles
franchement et je le dis sincèrement il
est très mignon chars oui oui l'est pas
c'est pas moi c'est retrouver plein
demain je te le dire regarde mais moi
j'ai trouvé donc
[Rires]
non le feu sur physiquement et il est
très mignon charles franchement il est
plutôt mignon il a des beaux yeux et
qualité c'est ce que m'a dit que celle
de suite non mais c'est ça oui c'est
vrai donc charles c koi tu étais pas
trois tailles tate à jaime une radio est
ce que tu crois qu'un blocage t'arrives
pas à à dire voilà que deux à passer le
cap d'embrasser une fille donc tu ne
t'attends qu'une fille fasse le premier
pas qu'est ce qui se passe donc d'un
blocage au fait et si j'y arrive pas
elle verrait le jeu mais même être les
réseaux sociaux par exemple maintenant
cette affaire la mienne on peu derrière
un écran développer des relations et
puis peut-être se mettre en confiance
même ça ça vous bloque alors elle l'a
stéphane edouard qui est dans le public
est parti stéphane on a acheté des idées
à stéphane stéphane justement vous avez
écrit un livre qui dit cinq ans que le
son pour séduire quand vous voyez le cas
de charme parce que charge que vous avez
très envie d'avoir une relation d'avoir
une fiancée oui la voix là et ça ça vous
pourrit la vie ou vraiment au quotidien
ou pas du tout si ce que beaucoup de mes
amis qu'on parle donc ils vous disent
quoi vos amis je vais changer mon style
que nous devons changer mon style au
fond je trouve
alors franchement je vous dis la vérité
je le dis je pense vraiment je trouve
que franchement le cas mais est le
problème et c'est passé pato style à
petit feu
il faut pas se tromper c'est pas
extérieurement que tu as besoin
d'évoluer straumann qu'un garçon comme
comme tous les autres qui a quatre
charmantes à tes qualités étaient des
faux c'est une performance et
psychologiques un blocage psychologique
est ce que tu t'es ma c'est toi est ce
que tu te désire à ses charmes est ce
que tu peux répondre à ces questions où
j'étais juste physiquement trouve de
cochons sont alors charles visagiste je
te le dis ah non mais vraiment ah non
merde tu te prends la tête alors est ce
que tu es accompagnés par quelques noms
stéphane stéphane edouard sociologue
donc je les dis là est craintif 50e sont
pour séduire qu'est ce que vous pourriez
dire à charles quels conseils pour
aiguiller alors bravo au titre du livre
vous savez series chez les éditeurs qui
choisissent les titres donc le accord en
fait c'est 50 leçons pour séduire mais
en fait c'est un livre de cuisine
khalil et l'école des hommes n'est pas
marion m'a dit il faut faire un petit
peu plus tassier donc mais tu mets ça
comme titre et c'est nous qui décidons
parce que c'est nous l'éditeur d'accord
à travers donc les titres de livres
c'est souvent comme ça par rapport à
charles charles comprenons c'est ça oui
pour moi c'est ni à l'extérieur ni
intérieur c'est simplement que tu es
imbibé de ce qu'on appelle la psy rose
l'abc rose c'est la psychologie à l'eau
de rose
on en a entendu un petit peu ce soir
d'ailleurs consistant à baignés le
garçon d'à le faire communier dans la
chapelle de la bien-pensance à lui
dessiner une espèce de femmes qui
n'existe absolument pas et en gros
chaque fois qu'il est confronté à une
femme réelle
il est confronté il devient schizophrène
parce qu'il se rend compte qu'elle ne
fonctionne absolument pas comment lui
vend donc on lui vend une femme qui va
être sensible à sa timidité à sa poésie
à son introversion et c est en réalité
ils voient que dans le lait déterminant
réel de la traction ça va être la
notoriété le statut le bad boy l'enfoiré
et c est donc en réalité ils développent
une espèce de double dialogue avec un
qui nous tient ce soir mais dont beac
auquel il ne croit absolument pas et je
vous invite à regarder son sourire parce
que ça c'est quelqu'un qui l'a il a
compris qu'on a quelque chose devrait
donc y tient une espèce de discours
comme ça très accréditant pour les
femmes jean cagnard il saura pas ce qui
vous dit vrai vous pensez qu'il
je cassais si je le dis c'est que c'est
que je le pense il y là il a fait un bon
diagnostic que si je peux dire stéphane
doiron pas du tout vu de nos sites j'ai
une question quels conseils on pourrait
lui donner juste avant de moi ce que je
lui conseille c'est de désapprendre tout
ce qu'on te dit sur la femme et de
regarder la femme réelle en réalité tu
l'idéaliste raw et l'idéal ''sans trop
tu es tu lui fournit une espèce de
discours préformaté un peu faisandée
frelaté qui l'intéressent pas la femme
reine n'est pas sensible à tata bien
pensants soit à ou à tartas bienfaisance
et non ça donc donc il faut qu'il faut
qu'ils passent outre tout ça il faut
qu'il arrive à surmonter ce à quoi il
faut qu'il arrive à ne plus projeté
devant ses yeux ce qu'il a derrière la
tête il faut qu'il arrive à regarder
vers quoi je vais jusqu'au bout
en affaires du media ltd rentrer chez
lui la rive à se départir d'un discours
féministe qui contraint beaucoup
d'hommes à rester seul et à finir avec
extra et à nourrir une rancoeur sans
cesse croissante envers les femmes
voilà alors mais je dis vous aviez une
question pour pour chat si effectivement
tu n'arrives pas à l'être à tirer enfin
tu n'arrives pas à conclure avec une
femme est ce que tu as déjà essayé avec
un mec non non non mais là vous êtes
attiré par les femmes
oui voilà nom qu'il a mais comment
calculer comment tu peux savoir être
attiré par les femmes si tu sais pas ce
que c'est mais non mais cela n'a rien à
mes ça n'a rien à voir
en fait tu dis des conneries ce nom
beaucoup n'avaient pas question de tout
à l'heure non mais je les adore j'aime
beaucoup me dit mémé jeudi frérot là il
et il sait qu'il a il sait qu'il est
attiré par plainte ait attiré par tant
de femmes et il attend comme on dit tu
as pris ta eu des reçus ou bien tu as
même car ils m'aiment pas jusque là mais
j'ai eu beaucoup de refus
et voilà bon bah non c'est déjà bien
mais c'est le problème vient des lilas
charles est ce qu'il ya un type de femme
quand tu fermes les yeux dans l'absolu
qui t'attire plus qu'une qu'un autre
type est ce que tu es plus blonde que
que brune et en espagne intéresse pas de
l'écart d'âge sera pas le cas mais ce
qu'il ya un team de vitry obligé de
répondre merci faut lui dire ce pays
c'est qu'il faut qu'il soit accompagnée
des moyens dont c'est le métier voilà
madame ka shing justement gymkhana
l'issue est sexologue est ce que est ce
que vous auriez vous aussi un conseil à
donner à charles est ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui devrait peut-être venir au
revoir je sais pas des dites nous oui
tout à fait
je pense qu'il faut que ça ait
effectivement il ya une une démarche de
remise en question de lui et c'est pas
effectivement entourage je pense qu'il
ya quelque chose à regarder à
l'intérieur donc dans vos rapports de
votre rapport aux femmes
en règle générale et puis et puis
peut-être other aussi l'image des hommes
quelle confiance en vous vous avez
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un homme face à
une femme et donc du coup interrogé
aussi l'image de l'homme et puis moi je
pense que c'est vraiment s'ils se
connecter à ton instinct primal ce que
la femme ce qui va la tirer c'est aussi
l'homme qui va dégager quelque chose est
en fait là je sens charles que tu crois
que tu que tu retiens des bouquets
vraiment travailler mais en fait ça se
travaille
ça se travaille vraiment avec ça se
décide
je voulais je voulais dire que en fait
on
les hommes de plus en plus moi dans ma
clinique je sais pas si c'est pareil
mais moi je vais je crois de plus en
plus d'hommes qui ont des troubles du
désir qui ont de moins en moins
confiance en eux qu'ils se disent qu'ils
ont du mal à se situer face à une femme
qui bat qui est sorti de la soumission
qui ce qui s'affirme est qui et qui fait
que l'homme est en demande de tendresse
beaucoup plus qu'avant alors que il
bénéficie d'une image avait bénéficié
il souffre plutôt une image médiatique
qui est plutôt agressif plutôt négative
et donc du coup il est complètement un
porte-à-faux un homme avec bon ce qui se
passe en ce moment
médiatiquement les les hashtags balance
t'emporte mitu etc c'est déjà suspect
presque d'être un homme
et ça ça balance quelque chose de
négatif alors que dans l'ordre dans ce
que je vois moi c'est déjà demain deux
groupes de paroles d'hommes par exemple
eh bien il souffre beaucoup de cette
image là parce qu'ils sont heureux ils
se reconnaissent pas ils sont de
tendresse ou d'hommes qui sont perdus
eric naulleau ya la solution
psychanalytique sexologue et jérôme dray
c'est vrai il faut couper comme moi il
viendra vous au cap d'agde
c'est vrai que je vous avoue dit ray
charles ou non ces refrains genre ouais
moi je crois que la solution est ce que
c'est patronale
[Musique]
d'abord la seule noyelles à la cause que
tu lui demandes de la cour jeu d'être
venus a ouï dire je voudrais poser une
question à charles charvet aujourd'hui
on sait bien que c'est pas comme il ya
quelques décennies
les filles elles attendent pas toujours
d'être dragué allô allô dragon peut
aussi quand tu es le taux est un garçon
charmant
tu as chairman tu as des qualités elton
radio parfois les filles et peut-être
alors que tu ne sens pas je vais vous
dire mes accomplissements papier c'est
compliqué agathe franchement on va
battre charles moi je trouve très haut
je trouve franchement très mignon et je
pense que charles que tu veux que je
voudrais la vie d'une voilà le problème
vient même âge de ton physique de ton
corps et c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est que
ça se passe dans ta tête d'un blocage
d'une timidité presque maladive et c'est
vrai que ça c'est pathologique c'est
quelque chose que tu dois parler
travailler pour t'ouvrir et tu vas
trouver l'amour et tu vas etre trés
situera en cause la grèce que juste
c'est mignon était open bord la minorité
doit arrêter là moi aussi à la mode chez
quelqu'un que j'ai envers leur confiance
en moi du tout étonné il ya un
témoignage là
[Rires]
aller là bas j'étais quelqu'un avant
qu'ils n'avaient pas confiance en moi et
franchement j'ai envie de te dire un
truc plus toi toi déjà à toi même avant
de vouloir plaire aux autres exacto pop
aux pauvres en une émission il est passé
de jessica des marseillais à nietzsche
bravo à toi et ça vraiment au jeu se
trouve top
voilà et je te dit tu vas je te dis tu
as assez faux problème tu vas ça va très
vite su régler pourquoi les furies ces
courageux que massé
[Applaudissements]